The plan here is to create a database
for Wittr that stores these posts.
When Wittr loads via a service worker,
it does so without going to the network.
It fetches the page skeleton and
assets straight from the cache.
Now, at the moment,
we have to go to the network for posts.
We're going to change that.
Instead, we'll get posts from
the database and display them.
Meaning, we're now showing post
content before we go to the network.
Then we'll connect the web
socket to get updated posts.
As shown here, web sockets bypass both
the service worker and the HTTP cache.
Then as new posts arrive, we'll add
them to our database for next time.
First thing we're going to
do is populate the database.
We'll deal with displaying
its contents later.
If we take a look in public > js > main,
IndexController.js, we can see a method
is called to open the web socket.
And in that method, we can see
a listener for the message event.
And that hands off to onSocketMessage,
passing in the data it received.
OnSocketMessage parses the data with
JSON, then passes it to addPosts.
Let's take a look at that data
by putting a console.log here.
Over in the browser, I'm going to
check Force updates on page load so
I can get that JavaScript
change straight away.
And there are the logs.
We can see that posts have an ID,
a time property, data on avatar, and
a message body.
We want to store these objects
straight into IndexedDB.
There's an obvious primary key here, id.
And we'll want to be able to
display them in date order, so
we'll need to create an index on time.
And it looks like I get to
take the next few minutes off,
because the Mike alarm is ringing.
Mike, one for the student to do?
>> Yep, it sure is.
Let's dive in.